In a surprising turn of events,
women and minority voters
are actually the reason why Trump got re elected.
Just where it stands right now,
it looks like he gained about 5% point among African American voters,
especially among African American men,
and about 7% with Hispanic voters.
Then we heard so much talk about how suburban women. Hi,
we're going to be overwhelmingly in support of Harris.
The reporters covering the election
were surprised to find that Trump outperformed
well beyond anyone's expectations with suburban women.
These numbers seem to highlight a movement away from identity politics.
Women and minority voters are sick of being told, hey,
you're a woman, you have to side with us.
You're African American, you must side with us.
It's getting old. And instead,
people are really starting to look at the policies,
starting to realize how phony the left has been
about trying to win women
and trying to win minorities.
All of the like, women supporting women,
and you're not black if you don't vote for this person.
People are getting sick and tired of that.
It is demeaning. Women are more than just their gender.
Minorities are more than just their ethnicity.
We have brains, we know how to read.
We care about policy
more than we care about fitting into some kind of club.
That is becoming more and more evident
as we're seeing these election results come out.
A lot of celebrities and politicians on the left
think that They own these demographics of people.
They think that we need to be loyal to them,
get their rhetoric and their policies hurt us.
And so many people are starting to realize that.
And that is why you saw Trump victory.